hello
welcome to the section on non-quadratic
losses
so far we've talked mainly about
regression that is the case when the
target variable
is a real number or
a real vector
now we've seen several different
predictors for such things including
things such as neural networks
and simple linear predictors as well as
more complicated things such as trees
and we've seen quadratic losses
and a few other example loss functions
and so today i want to go through a few
more different
non-quadratic loss functions and
talk about how the resulting predictors
behave when we use those
as losses in empirical risk minimization
so when we're solving the empirical risk
minimization problem
the empirical risk the average loss
is simply one on n the sum from i is one
up to n
of the loss evaluated at y hat i y
i where y hat is the predicted
value at position x i
so y hat i is g theta of x i
now very often the loss function
l of y hat y the intention of it is
that it's measuring the discrepancy
between y hat
and y now how much is the deviation
between y hat and y and so as a result
it's very common that the
loss function looks like a penalty
function
p of y hat minus y
here p can take several different forms
we've seen for example the square
penalty r squared
where the resulting loss function is
therefore the square of y hat minus y
here are y hat minus y is the prediction
error
or the residual um
if you've got a scalar y then r is
greater than zero means that our
predictor is overestimating
and r is less than zero means that our
predictor is underestimating
not all loss functions have this form
we've seen
for example the percentage
error which had a form which could not
be expressed as the
as a penalty function of y hat minus y
so if we have a penalty function it
tells us about how much we object to
different values of prediction error
very often p of zero is zero and p of
r is greater than or equal to zero for
every other r
um very often p is symmetric
p of minus r is p of r in which case we
really
are only determining the penalty based
on the
magnitude or that is the absolute value
of the prediction error
sometimes p is asymmetric p of minus r
is not
p of r and in which case we get
a different amount of penalty depending
on whether we're overestimating or
underestimating
now let's look at two common penalty
functions here is the
square penalty function versus the
absolute value
penalty function so
when we're using the square penalty
that's p
of r is r squared well when the
prediction error is very small well
then the penalty is really very very
small small squared
when the prediction error is large well
then the penalty is
extremely large large squared
if you compare this with the absolute
penalty we'll see that the absolute
penalty
responds less for small prediction
errors the penalty is
larger than the square penalty and for
large prediction errors the penalty is
smaller
than the square penalty
now here's another one we've seen before
when we were looking at quantiles this
is the tilted
absolute penalty function is this
parameterized by tau
it's an absolute value but it's tilted
and so
when r is negative the
penalty is minus tau times r
and when r is positive it's 1 minus 10
times r
and tau is somewhere between zero and
one
when tau is a half the tilted absolute
penalty function
isn't tilted it becomes the same as
one-half the absolute value of
r so we have the same penalty for
underestimating as
overestimating when tau is
greater than a half well then it's worse
to underestimate than to overestimate
remember the residual is y hat minus
y so the residual is positive means
that y hat is greater than y
and so when tau is greater than a half
well then our penalty is less for
positive r than for negative r
and similarly similar similarly when tau
is less than a half
it's worse to overestimate than to
underestimate
now the penalty function
expresses how you feel about large and
small
prediction errors about positive and
negative prediction errors
and as a result they drive the predictor
to prefer certain making certain types
of predictions
um in other words the choice of the
penalty function is going to change the
shape
of the histogram of prediction errors
remember how we construct a histogram we
look at all the residuals
and we divide them up into bins and we
display this as a bar
graph which shows the distribution of
residuals
so here's an example here we constructed
random data
300 data records each one of which
has a scalar y and a 30 dimensional
u and then we append a constant 1
so that x starts with 1 and then has 30
random numbers afterwards
and we use a 50 50 test train split here
and here the residual
is y hat minus y so the ice residual
is theta transpose x i minus y i
and we plotted here the histogram of the
residuals
for the the predictor
that minimizes the empirical risk and
we've done this in two cases
the first case is the top case
where we're using a square penalty
and so this curve here
is our penalty function and we can see
we've got some distribution of residuals
and if we look at that in the
test data we get a fairly similar
distribution of residuals as we'd expect
now we also try this with the
loss function being
the tilted penalty of the residual
so in other words the loss of y hat
comma y
is the tilted penalty function
of y hat minus y
and what do we see
we see that on the right hand side of
this plot
there's many fewer
residuals many fewer data points for
which
the residual is positive then there are
data points for which the residual
is negative because the
penalty is much greater for
producing a positive residual in other
words for overestimating
than for underestimating and so our
predictor
the predictor that is chosen by
empirical risk minimization
turns out to be a predictor that prefers
to underestimate than to overestimate
and that extends also to the test data
much as we might expect
that there's far fewer data points on
the right hand side
of the test data plot test residual
histogram
than there are on the left hand side now
i want to switch to
another type of error
that we might want to shape
and that's the case of outliers and this
is called robust
fitting so in some applications you have
a few data points that are just
wrong that are just way off sometimes
this occurs because when the data was
entered or transcribed it was
entered incorrectly there's an error in
the decimal point position or somebody
just
made a typo other times they're
caused by sensor failures or
various types of anomalies that occurred
when the data
was collected and these are
points are called outliers and
a consequence of having outliers even if
you've got any very few of them
is that the erm can pick up a very poor
predictor
now there are several methods for
removing outliers
here's one create a predictor
just based on the entire data set
and now look through your data points
and for each data point compute the
residual compute the prediction error
and those data points that have very
large prediction errors
mark them as outliers and remove them
from the data set
and then refit if you've still got poor
prediction
so a large empirical risk go through and
do it again
now this method can work well it's not
easy to implement because one has to
decide what it means to have a large
prediction error and it's certainly
possible to
choose that poorly and not be aware of
that
there's another way of removing outliers
or at least handling outliers and that
is to use a penalty function
that's less sensitive to outlier data
points
and we're going to look at that in this
section
these kind of penalty functions are
called robust
they a robust penalty function is one
that has low sensitivity
to outliers
and the idea is is that the way you make
a penalty function robust is you make
sure
that it grows more slowly for large
prediction errors
in particular than the square penalty
and so that means that the
predictor will not be predisposed
to avoiding those large prediction
errors which presumably occur
with the outliers so they respond a bit
more gracefully to the outliers
so instead of the error
in the in other words instead of the
empirical risk being
dominated by the
loss and a few very large
values of y
because the loss function doesn't grow
so rapidly
with y hat minus y
those aren't the values that dominate
the empirical risk anymore
and we end up with a robust predictor
that fits most of the data
reasonably well
now the most famous robust penalty
function is called the huber penalty
function
this is named after a swiss statistician
named peter huber
and it looks like this
between
it is a function which is defined in
two pieces uh first it's defined
for small r and then separately it's
defined for
large r and so the transition value will
be
alpha and so for r with absolute value
less than alpha
it's just the quadratic function
it's just r squared and for r
greater than alpha
it's a linear function
and the slope of that and the intercept
of that linear function are chosen
so that they meet up very nicely with
the quadratic at alpha and here alpha is
one
and so here we've got a function which
behaves
exactly like the quadratic when r is
small when the residual is small it will
penalize
the residual exactly the same amount as
the quadratic penalty would
but when the residual gets large
it penalizes much less
than the quadratic penalty would
and there's an explicit formula here for
the huber penalty it's r
squared when r is small and some linear
function of
r when r is large
um
let's look at what it does
so here what we have is we have
a simple scalar erm problem
we have a bunch of data points
and what's plotted here is on this
horizontal axis
we have u
and on this vertical axis we have
v and we'll have the embedding that x
is equal to 1 u
and y is equal to v so we're going to
use a linear
predictor here so we're going to use y
hat
is equal to theta transpose
1 u
and we're fitting a straight line to a
bunch of data
we have a whole bunch of data points
sitting in the middle here
and then we have out here and out here
some data points that are outliers
and as a result if we use the square
penalty function so we solve this
problem using least squares
we end up with a predictor
which is that straight line there which
as we can see is doing rather poorly
at fitting this data set
now we can think about it as these data
points
are pulling the line down
and these data points are pulling
the line up and we're twisting
our predictor
and as a result even though we've got
many more
data points that are not outliers then
data points that are outliers what
matters
is the square of the distance between
the predicted value and the actual data
point
and so it's the square of the distance
between a data point down here
and the predicted value up here that
distance
squared is how much that data point is
going to contribute
to the empirical risk these
data points
contribute those distance squared
and so even though there are many more
data points
that are true data points
the distance of the outliers from the
predictor is so large
that by the time you've squared the
magnitude of those corresponding
residuals
the resulting terms
in the empirical risk end up swamping
the true
loss terms in the empirical risk
the humor if we solve the same problem
but instead of minimizing the
empirical risk with a square loss we
minimize the empirical risk with a huber
loss
we end up with a predictor that looks
like this
it's still being influenced by the
outliers but as we can see it's
influenced a lot less
and it's doing a reasonable job at the
rest of the data as a result
now you can take this further you can
say okay well
i'd like a penalty function which is
even less
sensitive to outliers than the huber
penalty
here's a penalty that we might call the
log cuber
again within
a particular region here alpha is one so
between minus one and one when the
residual is between minus one and one
we've got a quadratic function
and when the residual is larger than
that in absolute value
we've got a logarithmic function
and we can choose the terms in that
logarithmic function
such that uh
it joins up nicely with the quadratic
with the right
slope at that point notice that even
though it says log y
squared there of course the log of y
squared is just 2 log y
um
and um so we've got a something which is
quadratic for small one and logarithmic
for large y
and that means that when we compare this
with the
quadratic loss at large r we're really
discounting
a lot very large residuals
we have a diminishing penalty
at large residuals or a large y
effectively
and so if we can if we apply the log
cuber
loss function to our same data problem
to our same data fitting problem
we have here
a fit which really parses passes
straight through the middle of the true
data points
and effectively ignores the outliers
we can see this in terms of the error
histograms as well
here um the top
row of this these plots show
the results from applying the square
loss function here
is our predictor we can see we've got
a residual of training errors so these
are the training residuals
which are spread out between minus two
and two
and we see very similar things in tests
that we do on train
as we should uh
in this plot on the left some of the
data points are marked blue and some of
them are marked red
the blue ones are the training points
and the red ones are the test points
here's the huber
to fit the results from using the huber
loss function
and we can see that what's happened
is that the residuals have split up
right there's a whole bunch of residuals
that are now very close to zero
those are the true data points and we
can really clearly see the outliers
and the same thing we see over
a test when we apply the log cuber
we can see that the training residuals
near zero get even smaller and get even
closer to zero
we've only got two bars rather than four
bars
um in the middle and the same thing in
test
so one could from either
the huber or the log cuber immediately
identify
the residuals and we could simply say
these data points here we're going to
remove from our data set
and then we're going to fit again and of
course when we fit again having removed
those data points and we could use any
one of these loss functions
and it would be fine
it's also important to notice here that
when you look at plots like the ones on
the left it's tempting to think well
why do we need a machine like this in
order to be able to identify outliers
and the answer is because here x and y
are one dimensional
if x is in a million dimensions and y
is in a hundred dimensions well then
suddenly we can't
make these kind of plots anymore and we
can't see which data points are outliers
and which ones are not
nonetheless we can still plot the
residuals
or at least the norm of the residuals
and the histograms of the norms of the
residuals
and be able to identify outliers that
way
the next topic i want to address is
quantile aggression
the idea here is that we're going to do
erm or regularized erm
and we're going to use a loss function
which is generated by the tilted
penalty function and that's called
quantile
regression
and the intuition is that when tau is
greater than a half
that's going to make it worse to
underestimate
and so we're going to end up with
predictions that are
high when tower is less than a half it
makes it worse to overestimate so we're
going to end up with predictions that
are low
now we can be explicit as to exactly how
high or low
these predictions are
and the way this works is that we're
going to assume that the predictor
has the form
theta 1 plus
g theta tilde of x
and that means that say theta one might
correspond
to the linear predictor where
x one is one and so the resulting
prediction has a theta 1
term in it and we're going to assume
that cd1 is not regularized
the other components of theta might be
regularized
and g tilde of theta of x may not be a
linear predictor it could it's an
arbitrary predictor
in other words that the regularizer r of
theta does not depend on theta one
so we might have bridge regression where
we're using the
square regularizer and so r of theta
is theta 2 squared plus theta 3 squared
all the way up
to theta d squared
now if you do this then it turns out
that on the training set
when you're using the regularized erm
predictor
the one minus tau quantile of residuals
is zero
in other words the fraction of data for
which we overestimate
is tau and that's
why it's called quantile regression
if the predictor generalizes and we
would expect to see the same thing in
the test data that we see
in the training data notice that in the
training data
this is exact apart from the possibility
that there might be
data points with repeated residual
values
so we can create predictors for many
different tiles which give many
different
quantile estimates for a particular x
so let's look at why we get this
phenomena
remember what we saw in the section on
constant predictors
we saw that if we minimize
that if we minimize the empirical risk
1 on n the sum from i is 1 up to n
of the tilted loss
of theta minus y i
that the resulting theta has the
property
the theta is the tau
quantile of the y
eyes
now here we're minimizing something
different
we're minimizing 1 on n
the sum over i is 1 up to n
of p tau of
g theta of x
i minus y i
so that's not quite the same but let's
split it up
by using the property of g theta
and that is that g theta is theta 1
plus g tilde theta of x i minus y
i and we're going to minimize this
over theta and that means our problem
is minimize over theta
l of theta now theta has multiple
components theta one through c to d
and we can regard this minimization as
equivalent to
it is equivalent to minimum over theta 1
minimum over the rest of theta
l of theta
and once we've done this part of the
minimization here
what's left is
a minimization that looks exactly like
the one we had before
it looks like this where now
we have theta 1
plus a term g theta tilde
x i minus y i which doesn't depend on
theta
right 1. a result theta 1 is going to
turn out to be the tau
quantile of y
i minus g theta tilde of x i
we can say that another way the fraction
of the data points for which y i
minus g theta tilde x i is less than or
equal to zero
is less than or equal to theta one is
around tau
subtracting theta 1 from both sides
gives us the residual
and so the fraction of i for which the
residual
is greater than or equal to 0 is around
tau
the fraction of data points for which we
overestimate is around tau
an example here we have again some
random data
that we've solved erm for
where we're using a loss function
which is a tilted loss function and we
can see
exactly what we expect to see when tau
is point one ninety percent of the data
has a residual which is less than zero
when tau is point nine ten percent of
the data
has a residual which is less than zero
and when tau is a half
about half of the data is one side and
half the data is the other side
let's look at an example of erm
where we're trying
to fit data here we have
a bunch of data points again similar
one-dimensional
u one-dimensional v and we're going to
embed
by x is equal to one u
so we'll have a constant term and
a linear term in our predictor
we've got blue points here which are
training points and red points here
which are test points
and we're going to fit a straight line
production model
using the tilted loss at three different
values of towel
and these are the resulting predictors
now this is tau is point one
a predictor for which
our prediction at any given value of u
let me pick a value of u say i pick
point three
the prediction is somewhere around one
which is clearly above
most of the data the prediction
the predictor prefers to overestimate
than to underestimate with towers a half
we get a predictor that's somewhere in
the middle
and when tau is 0.1 we get a predictor
that prefers to underestimate then to
overestimate
another way to view this data is to plot
the predicted value and the true
value for the data points on one plot
so here we have the true value of
v or of y and here
we have the predicted value v hat on the
vertical axis of each of these three
plots
now in the ideal world v hat would be
equal to v
our predictor would produce perfect
predictions
but of course we know that's not very
likely particularly with this data set
and so
we see that v hat and v
are spread out so in the ideal world
would have v and v
would be a bunch of data points that
would live on
the diagonal and that would be the
perfect predictor
if you've got a predictor that tends to
overestimate
well then the predictor tends to produce
v
hats that are greater than v and that
means it tends to produce
points that are in this half
of the plane and if you've got a
predictor that prefers to underestimate
it tends to produce v hats less than v
and we end up with points
in this half of the plane
and we can
look at if this is training data
we can look at our data and count and we
would find
that 90 of the points
are above the line here and 90
of the points are below the line over
here
and uh with uh
towers and a half well then we should
see exactly half of the points
on one side of the line and half of the
points on the other side of the line
so there's another way of plotting this
data and that is
to look at the cumulative distribution
of the residuals so for any given
q we
going to plot q here on the
horizontal axis and then on the vertical
axis
we will plot the number of data points
for which the residual is
less than q
and in particular i've got three plots
here
one shows the residuals when
we've computed the predictor using tau
as 0.1
another when we've computed the
predictor using tau is 0.5
and a third using the showing the
residuals
winter is 0.9 and if we look at this
plot
and we look at q is equal to zero
this the green predictor with tau is a
half
shows us that exactly one half
of the training data points are less
than zero
have residual less than zero
when tau is point one we see exactly
fraction point nine so exactly ninety
percent
of the data points have a residual
less than zero when tau is point nine
we see exactly ten percent
of the data points have a residual less
than zero
and so here we're seeing that the
quantile regression is giving us exactly
the quantiles we expected it to
on the training data on the test data
let's have a look how well we did
at a q is zero
we're getting almost exactly 0.1
the tau is 0.9 now we're getting 0.45 so
we're getting 45 percent of the data
have a residual less than zero with
towers a half
and we're getting 85 percent of the data
have a residual less than zero
with towers 0.1 so even on the trading
data
we're getting quantiles for the residual
that match pretty much what we expected
to get
let's summarize loss function is often
expressed as a penalty function of the
residual
residual is r equals y-hat minus y
and the last function expresses how much
we object to different values
of the residual different choices of
loss function give us different erm
predictors
and in particular there are two types
that are very important
one is robust fitting when you're
fitting data with outliers
you use a penalty function which
increases more slowly than the square
penalty function
and that gives you robustness to the
outliers
if you're interested in producing
predictors
that prefer to overestimate or under
masturbate
the data
then you can do quantile rejection
regression
and in quantile regression you fit data
which gives
and in such a way that you get a
specific fraction
of other estimates and you can choose
that fraction by choosing tau